you know lamar jackson's probably the
most dangerous player in the league
um because there are times you can do
everything on everything right on
defense and um can't catch him
or you know he can throw a ball sidearm
underneath of a free rusher and complete
a pass
i think that you got to have a resilient
attitude when you play him and you know
that a playmaker like him is going to
make some plays you just have to limit
his big plays and you have to stay
resilient
jim schwartz eagles defensive
coordinator getting ready for the 2019
mvp to show up in philadelphia the
eagles won three and one let's start our
week week six preview what's more likely
style right there what is more likely
lamar jackson throws for 250 or more
yards or carson wentz the eagles
quarterback throws zero interceptions
chris what's more like i'm going easy
there lamar jackson throws her 250 plus
yards i mean not that i think that's a
definite but i just carson wentz
throwing zero interceptions i doubt that
i mean the eagles won't be able to run
the ball they're gonna have to throw the
ball every play like they always do
nobody's gonna be open except for fulgum
every now and then and he's gonna i mean
carson wentz he threw two interceptions
last week one was you know the game was
over he had to make something happen but
i mean he made so many great throws and
great plays in that game that i just you
know that goes unnoticed but i just
think between that and yes they got to
rely on him too much that raven's
defense he's going to throw an
interception lamar might have a big day
too because the eagles play a lot of
man-to-man they'll leave their guys in
some vulnerable positions to where he
might be able to hit a few big shots and
take advantage of that
lamar jackson hasn't had more than 204
passing yards since week one when he
unleashed this new look passing
approach against the browns it just
hasn't been back at that level since
then the tennessee titans are hosting
the houston texans this weekend texans
1-4 titans 4-0 one of the last three
unbeaten teams what's more likely the
titans are helped by this covet 19.
everyone is pointing out that we had an
outbreak chip on their shoulder or are
the titans hurt by the short rest the
tuesday to sunday turn around i think it
i think with this one i would go the the
short rest might creep back in here on
them a little bit uh i mean they're
gonna have a chip on their shoulder yes
but
it's been a whirlwind for them i think
if you're going to make me choose you
know between the two
what is it going to be a whirlwind
whirlwind whirlwind world world wind
yeah it's a whirlwind
it's going all around the world and it's
windy but um yes i i guess i feel that
way i mean i they're gonna not gonna
lose that chip i don't think they're
gonna lose it but i also think they're
seeing a texans team with a little bit
of a fresh vibe and things like that hey
romeo connell we feel good and i i i
guess i just
i it's hard i'm shocked at how well they
played the other night i really am
yeah i i uh
what are you gonna do i think the titans
i think the titans are they
as long as mike frable keeps them from
realizing that no one's really all upset
all that upset with them at this point
they can preserve that that kind of
goofy
us against the world because god forbid
they had an outbreak vibe i mean it look
it's it's it's on the surface it's dumb
but if it works it's not go ahead right
and and i think i think that they're
they're just in this bubble they're in
this mindset they're in this mode and i
don't think it goes away
from tuesday to sunday and
and and i think the bigger risk is they
overlook the texans because who's coming
next week it's the pittsburgh steelers
the only other unbeaten for now team in
the afc i i that that's where i just
that's where i look at it as maybe being
like a little tired just from the
emotions of tuesday night knowing what
you got on the horizon
you know the texans hey we're better
than them we should win this game it is
a little worrisome there i do think the
titans will still win the football game
i would expect them to uh but i wouldn't
be shocked if the sean watson and
company kind of kept this closer than it
should be
yeah i i uh and you know what on the
surface is it fair to have the titans
have to turn it around after only five
days the bill's got an extra day to get
ready for they deserve it they deserve
the extra day they didn't they've been
put in this position by the titans so
the titans sorry the you're the ones
that did this and you get the shorts
there's the clip that mike vrabel can
play there's somebody's blaming the
titans but you're blacking the titans
it's your fault there's no one there's
no one to blame so please blame us so we
can use that as motivation to go out and
beat whoever the next opponent may be it
also helps that the texans frankly
aren't that good they've got to win
against the jaguars the jaguars have set
a record for
losing four straight games to previously
winless teams
uh atlanta speaking of winless teams
heading to minnesota the vikings are one
in four falcons owen five what's more
likely the falcons get the artificial
interim head coach bounce or
the vikings carry over momentum that
came from that near-miss win on the road
in seattle i'm gonna go with the vikings
here and the bump of the near-miss win
and everything like that you know
the vikings have shown at least some
glimmer of hope the last few weeks i
mean yeah they lose a heartbreaker to
seattle the week before that they played
damn good against the tennessee titans
and had them on the ropes i mean as you
know so
we've seen like an upward trend with the
the vikings even though it's only
translated to one win out of the last
three games
atlanta
i'm not doing anything with that
football team until i see something that
i just don't see it and then that
defense you know versus the minnesota
run game that's
worrisome you know kirk cousins and
jefferson and thielen they're kind of
becoming dangerous there um you know i
like raheem morris he's gonna bring some
new energy to the football team but
there's only so much that new energy can
overcome
and in between the close loss to the
titans and the close loss to the
seahawks the vikings did get bill
o'brien fired yeah that's right by
beating the text so they they were the
last team
to face
the
permanent coach of the texans they're
the first team to face the interim coach
of the falcons and
i just think that this falcons team is
impervious to an artificial interim head
coach bounce i think that they all know
the winds of change are blowing hard and
based upon the way arthur blank and rich
mckay addressed the situation in the
media on monday no one is safe no one's
getting out until the new coaching staff
decides to get rid of them and i
wouldn't be surprised if some guys were
jostling behind the scenes to maybe get
traded now even though rich mckay has
said they want to preserve the roster as
much as possible so the new gm and the
new head coach can decide what to do
with it so i agree with you there and
we'll be doing our mega pix podcast
later today but i'm already leaning a
best bet for the vikings because they're
only given three and a half points wow
falcons here's the thing
the vikings going into their bye week
and they go to green bay after that if
they lose this one
they are
done yeah done done done
one in five going into the buy we the
packers in green bay on the other end
done
are you going to wear a jersey today on
the mega pixel podcast
which jersey vikings no the one you got
on right now you nitwit it's a kit it's
a kit liverpool kit oh they call it the
terminology they call it a kit i don't
know when you said i can't i was like
wait did they send you a kit of
liverpool stuff built this shirt what i
built this no i thought they met like
you know you had a kid in there that had
a hat and a jersey and some cool socks
like it was a kit of stuff so they
called the jersey the kit sorry i did
not know that you sound like y'all from
leather paul
here's the thing i probably will
wear this
for the mega pix podcast because we only
have an hour in between and it usually
is a whirlwind for me in that hour it's
a windy world you're right yes
all right the washington football team
you know what there's a lot of bad games
this weekend we've been spoiled by some
good games holy crap this this is one
where this is what uh pete says we're
saving the good games for later i don't
care where are the good games there's
still some bad games this weekend
washington one and four at giants oh and
five what's more likely washington
trails at halftime or the giants trail
at halftime here's why the giants have
trailed at halftime every game this
season and this note from jp finley of
nbc sports washington
the washington football team has trailed
at halftime by at least 10 points in
seven straight games going back to last
season it ties an nfl record with the
brooklyn dodgers from 1942 to 43 and the
1939 who can forget the 1939 chicago
card nobody
ten
seven straight games trailing at
halftime by ten or more points the
amazing thing is they've actually won at
least one of them i know it's amazing uh
and uh so somebody's gonna be well
unless it's a tie somebody's gonna be
trailing in halftime what's more likely
washington or the giants trailing at the
half so do we know the quarterback
situation quite yet i mean i know they
said kyle allen would yes so is he's
good he's good to go here's here's the
situation and this is interesting yeah
kyle allen fully participated in
practice yesterday with the left
shoulder injury dwayne haskins who
wasn't with the team on sunday due to an
illness non-covet illness
didn't practice yesterday due to an
illness and it just makes me wonder has
he just disengaged and if i was 23 and i
went from being future franchise
quarterback to cast into a corner and
you're not even going to be in uniform
for the game
i can't say i wouldn't have had a
four-day illness that may have been
embellished a little bit because look
you're showing me no respect whatsoever
you make me the 15th overall pick in the
draft and this is what you do to me less
than two years later are you kidding me
yeah so
awkward dynamic to say the least but it
looks like it's gonna be kyle allen yeah
okay well he is the dwayne house because
this isn't a tough spot there's no doubt
about that uh i think if i'm gonna go
with the giants trail at halftime i am i
think kyle allen showed me enough last
week to go okay yeah it's not a
superstar but he can move the ball down
the field we saw him make some throws
and a few runs ran in for that touchdown
showed a little more speed than you know
most people think he has the giants
offense
you know yeah they got the benefit of
playing the cowboys last week but
i i mean other than that it has shown no
signs of life and and washington's
defense is pretty damn good so i'm gonna
go with the giants trailing at halftime
i am
the last time these teams played week 16
2019 the giants actually led by 14 at
the half washington tied it up the
giants won in overtime they won the
battle and lost the war because that
game allowed washington to get in
position to draft chase young yeah so
right there's no tanking in football my
butt there should be because who cares
about what happened in week 16 between a
couple of bad teams you got chase young
on washington's roster for the next five
years at least maybe a lot longer that
means a held a lot more than a
meaningless game from december of 2019
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports